this great results about adding average
case complexity and he showed that if MP
can be efficiently solved on average by
deterministic algorithms
then we can solve up in determinist time
2 to the N divided by log n in the worst
case
and in his uh later work with bikito
larashima from the same assumption they
show that we can learn small circuits on
any unknown P poly sampleable
distributions
I know that leader of this results
says anything about comical capacity but
the proofs heavily rely on
uh panel combo of capacity and more
specifically KT
and in both cases we lead to
assume that MP can be uh solved on
average by determined algorithms
and if we
just assume that MP can be solved by a
randomized algorithm the proof no longer
work and the reasons that this result
the proofs long black box if you just
replace the average a determinist
average algorithm by uh
randomized average case algorithm
then we cannot just use as a bullet box
and get the same thing
so the question here is whether we can
extend it to the randomized setting
there are good reasons to consider a
randomized average case capacity and not
just the the domestic one but I will
lock that into the details
and in the Sandpaper where we introduced
the lotion of pkt
we also use this lotion to
extend the previous result uh to the
randomized setting so we show that if MP
can be efficiently solved on average by
randomized algorithm then we can still
get the first two algorithm
a faster randomized algorithm that
solves up
and we get we also get exactly this the
exact same learning consequence
as increased work
okay uh next I will
I'm going to uh talk about some some of
the very important properties of
Commonwealth complexity and one such
property is called a coding theorem so
the coding theorem for time bounded
comic book of capacity says that if you
have computable distribution D that
samples x with probability of x
then the Chromebook of capacity of X is
at most log
1 over P of x
and the proof of the coding filter and
crucially rise on the time unbounded
feature of Commonwealth capacity so the
question here is whether whether there's
a coding theorem for time bounded combo
of capacity say k poly
so if you want to show that this went to
low if there if we have a efficiency
sample of voltage Improvement the the
samples x with probability of X can
visit at the k-poly capacity of X is at
most log 1 over T of x
and in fact ntunes and I'll show that uh
this is true
if we assume a strong deep randomization
assumption but this result is
conditional
and you know join what with uh you call
Oliver and marvelous Siemens we get an
unconditional coding theorem for TK
quality so if there's an efficient
sample distribution T that samples x
with probability of X then we can say
that the PK poorly congression of X is
at most log
1 over T of x
and we can also show a Converse so um
the efficient sample ability of a string
correspond exactly to its PK poorly
capacity yeah
and
okay another important property in
Chromebook of capacity is called
symmetry of information
so we load that for string X and Y
the comic of capacitor of X and Y is
roughly at most common capacity of X
Plus The Chronic of convection of Y
gamma X and this is just because if we
want to get a program that brings X and
Y then we can first use the program that
brings X
and then use the program that prints y
given X
and symmetry of information for time and
Boundary common above capacity basically
says that this inequality
is tight in the sense that K of X and Y
is at least K of X Plus K of Y given x
minus some small term
and the reason why we call the symmetry
of information is because from the two
inequality we can get something
uh best analogous to what's called uh
simulation information in Shannon's
information Theory
and again the question here is does
symmetry information hold in the time
boundary setting
say for KT
and unlike the coding Theory below that
symmetry information is unlikely to hold
for KT
and that's because uh we know that if
one-way function S6 then signature of
information for KT fails
and uh
intuitively if we if we have a one-way
function f or let's say if we have a
one-way computation then from X we can
compute f of x efficiently but if we are
just given f of x we cannot get back X
efficiency
so that's an asymmetry of information
between these two strings if we take
into account the time
and longer than water Library formally
connects the existence of one-way
function to the failure of symmetric
information for KT
but the results only shows
One Directions
and since then has been uh okay since
that has been an open question uh
whether we can get some if and only if
statement between one-way functions and
symmetry of information and yeah
upcoming work with uhara rahulango um
we showed that one-way function exists
if and only if
some average case version of C major
information for pkt does lot hold
so again pkt seems to be the right
lotion to connect the one-way function
and symmetry of information
and in the same paper we have we also
use other properties of
pkt to characterize
um more complexity assumptions such as
plot equals to MP or MP star on
average
and there will be a talk on this in the
upcoming Workshop of the medical
capacity program
any questions
so your new condition on equivalence of
one-way functions how does it relate to
the average case hardness of ckt or
something is it in the same Spirit you
mean the last one yeah because there are
some other theorems like this right like
the new past theorems and so on yeah
first of all yeah it's unconditional so
the equivalency is unconditional and
compared to leopards new process that uh
wave function is excessive
like KT some uh KT is hard or average
and in this case we are not considering
like the highest of computing some
problem we consider whether the
properties of pkt holes whether
properties of time management capacity
holds
and so in some senses like different
are you so the question is what's the
what's the construction the arrow going
the other way so if you assume the
Symmetry fails then how do you is there
a simple way to describe the one wave
function construct
foreign
so let's uh take a coffee break now and
we'll resume at 11 30 and let's thank
all the speakers
[Applause]